how's it going Russia's beautiful
recently Justin Bieber did an ad
campaign for Calvin Klein and it turned
out the picture one real no look at its
[ __ ] legs look I wish it did so if
you want to become Calvin Klein Justin
Bieber fied all you have to do create a
new layer go to liquify and you're done
though his answer was a la Baker wasn't
it that's an appropriate amount and then
I think his junk was a lot bigger and
we're gonna have the Bulge tool
I think this if this tool was made for
this men with tiny penises not even the
bullish tool can save Justin then you
know you're in trouble huh looks like
he's wearing a diaper let's see here
before after very subtle you don't want
to expose yourself now that bulge
we need to crop out I'm cropping out
Justin Bieber's bulge this is this is a
great point in my life really though
seriously got that classic half-boner
going so it's all about looking natural
natural
let's see before after very realistic
with Photoshop you can change anything
so it's like why would you have hands so
let's get rid of those you no longer has
hands it does feel a little empty so
we're gonna give him a duck the color
and the contrast makes it not seem 100%
real so we're gonna have to adjust that
the duck seems really into that bowl
Mego looks so natural
let's see yet another before after
before after clearly amazing results
right away it's just the power of
Photoshop now they did do his muscles up
a blow bet so let's do that as well that
actually looks [ __ ] creepy now
another thing they did in the original
photo was making head a little smaller
which I thought was pretty interesting
so let's explore that I mean it looks so
natural now we just need to match the
contrast and the color
and there we have it folks almost as
good as the original after before
you're welcome beeps another Lee Justin
Bieber Kevin Kline photo yep what the
duck what's with the duck hand I don't
know
oh look he actually has a penis now he's
got a banana rumor has it this is the
original photo before Photoshop rumors
never wrong
surprisingly fangirls were really into
this photo well this is a lot of fun
let's do another one
I'm so confused I don't know what I'm
doing Justin actually wanted to be the
brand his penis is actually everywhere
on his body now stop making these
amazing pictures I don't have enough
storage space I'm like a shin but Justin
Bieber realistic bulge Justin Bieber Oh
fantastic Oh bye-bye Oh secure socket
Baba the leaked photo of the leaked
photo of Justin Bieber traffic control
what all right I spent way too much time
on this [ __ ] meat oh man all right when
you Photoshop underwear on top of a
shrimp you know it's time to stop so
like if you like this video I really
appreciate it hits ask our home brew
today thank you for watching and as
always stay awesome
you